[موسيقى]
اوقاتنا اعزائي المشاهدين نحييكم من
العربيه وهذه نشره التاسعه هذا المساء
قتلاني في تسلل بريانسك موسكو تعلن طرد
المنفذين خارج الحدود وكيف تصفها
على هامش اجتماعات العشرين في الهند لقاء
عابر بين بلينكن ينتهي بتبادل الاتهامات
حول زعزعه الاستقرار
في ايران تصميم بالمدارس واعدادات في
السجون العفو الدوليه تكشف شنق اربعه
وتسعين شخصا منذ بدايه العام الجاري
تزامنا مع حصولها على اسلحه امريكيه جديده
[موسيقى]
تفاصيل التاسعه تبدا من روسيا يوم مربكون
هناك تسببت به حادثه تسلل في مقاطعه
الحدوديه مع اوكرانيا سيما وانه اول هجوم
او اختراق من نوعه لروسيا منذ بدء الحرب
في اوكرانيا وبعد هذا الهجوم تبادلت موسكو
الاتهامات لكن قبل ذلك اعلنت روسيا طرد
المنفذين خارج حدودها بعد مقتل شخصين
اثنين واصابه طفل الرئيس فلاديمير بوتين
قال ان المنفذين نازيون جدد واصفا العمليه
بالارهاب الاوكراني اما فاعتبرته عمليه
روسيه مفبركه لاستفزاز اوكرانيا وبينما
تبادل الجانبان الاتهامات اعلنت المجموعه
التي اغتالت ابنه المفكر الروسي المقرب من
الكسندر دوغين تبنيها لهذه الهجمات في
بريانسك فيما قالت المخابرات الاوكرانيه
ان الهجوم نفذه معارضون من الداخل
الحرب مواجهه مفتوحه احيانا تتجاوز ظروف
الزمن والمكان من شرق اوكرانيا الى غرب
روسيا تستمر الاحداث المتسارعه حدث مقاطعه
داخل التراب الروسي قد يغير المعادله
ويفتح جبهه جديده المخابره الاوكرانيه
قالت ان الهجوم نفذه معارضون من الداخل ضد
نظام بوتين ويريدون القضاء عليه الرئيس
الروسي الذي الغى رحلته التي كانت مخططا
لها الى
الهجوم بالارهابي
اليوم نفذوا هجوما ارهابيا اخر نفذوا
جريمه اخرى على منطقه حدوديه وفتحوا النار
على مدنيين رغم رؤيتهم بان السياره مدنيه
ويجلس فيها مدنيون واطفاله هؤلاء الاشخاص
اخذوا على عاتقهم مهمه انتزاع ذاكرتنا
وتاريخنا وعاداتنا وحتى لغتنا ورغم ان
المجموعه التي نفذت الهجوم نشرت مقطعا
مصورا لعناصرها داخل المقاطعه
وهم يرفعون شعار الجيش الاوكراني قال
مستشار الرئاسه الاوكرانيه
ان الهجوم مفبرك ومزيف الى ذلك تبنت
المجموعه التي اغتالت ابنه المفكر الروسي
المقرب من الكريم
الهجمه فيبريانسك تطور جديد قد يغير مسار
الحرب رغم انفي صلتها بالموضوع خلال
الوجداني العربيه
قال نائب وزير الخارجيه الروسيه
لن تكون اول من يجري اختبارات نوويه وخلال
لقائه بالبعثه الروسيه في جنيف اوضح
ريابوف ان روسيا عليها الاستعداد
لسيناريوهات اسوء
لن نكون اول من يختبر جهازا نوويا صدقت
روسيا على معاهده الحظر الشامل للتجارب
النوويه في عام 2000 والتي سبقها وقف طويل
على التجارب النوويه اذا لم تختبر
الولايات المتحده جهازا نوويا فلن نقوم
بذلك لكن يجب ان نكون مستعدين للاسوء لابد
من اعاده صياغه مطلب تكرر من قبل نظرائنا
الامريكيين مؤخرا نقول ان الولايات
المتحده واوكرانيا بامكانهما ايقاف الحرب
اذا اتخذوا القرارات الصحيحه
وفي التطورات الميدانيه للحرب نشرت مجموعه
هوفاجنر مقطعا مصورا لقوتها داخل مركز
مدينه باخموت بعد قتال عنيف مستمر منذ
اسابيع وقال مؤسس المجموعه
في مركز مدينه باخمت
التطورات الميدانيه وتطورات الحرب اجمالا
في اوكرانيا نرصدها مع مراسلي العربيه
الان مباشره من الدنيا ومن موسكو رائد
الاغبر وعبد الجواد الرشد مرحبا بكما رائد
لعلي ابدا معك مع هذا الفيديو لمجموعه عن
وجودها في وسط جديد الوضع الميداني
والمعارك هناك في ضخمه هل يمكن القول ان
الروس احكموا قبضتهم على المدينه بهذه
المشاهد من وسط المدينه لفاجنر
مساء الخير صهيب بالفعل يعني المعارك
مستعره بالمحور الشرقي من اوكرانيا خاصه
مقاطعه
وبالاخص مدينه باخموت قوات فاجنر تطوق
المدينه مدينه باخمت من النواحي الثلاثه
الجنوبيه الشماليه والشرقيه لكن المعارك
الاسخن من الناحيه الشماليه بعد ان سيطرت
على عده بلدات اخرها يا قدنا تقدمت الان
قبل يعني ساعات قوات فاجنر نحو الغرب
لاكمال التطويق الطوق لم يكتمل حتى الان
هو من ثلاث نواحي ويحاول الجيش الروسي
اكمال الطوق من الناحيه الغربيه تقدمت نحو
بلده تدعى خروموفا المعارك الاندار من
الناحيه الشماليه والشرقيه من خروفا اذا
تمكن الجيش الروسي من دخول هذه البلده
والسيطره عليها يكون قاب قوسين او ادنى من
اقتحام البلده التاليه وهي بغداد اخر
المعاقل في المنطقه الغربيه التي تكمل
الطوق القوات الروسيه قوات فاجنر وصلت الى
مركز المدينه حسب الفيديو وتتقدم الى
الناحيه الغربيه حسب المعطيات من ارض
المعارك هناك طيب هذا تقدم روسي في لكن
عبد الجواد اسالك عن عمليه التسلل التي
حصلت في برياسك هذه العمليه التي وصفتها
روسيا بان منفذها هم نازيون جدد هل تكشفت
حقيقه ما جرى في برياسك
مساء الخير صهيب لك ولي رائد طبعا موسكو
تحدثت ولم يعني تقف عند وصف من تسلل من
الاراضي الاوكرانيه بالنازيين الجدد بل
تحدثت عن ان هذا العمل الارهابي طبعا
الروايه الرسميه تتحدث عن تسلل عشرات
المسلحين من الاراضي الاوكرانيه نحو هذه
المقاطعه الحدوديه المنتخبه للاراضي
الاوكرانيه طبعا العديد من الاعمال التي
شهدتها ضواحي هذه المدينه ضواحي بريانسك
يعني تمثلت في اطلاق النار على بعض
المدنيين ما ادى الى مقتل شخصين واصابه
طفل يبلغ من العمر 11 عاما وتم اجراء عمل
جراحي له بنجاح حسب الروايه الرسميه ايضا
طبعا تم زرع العديد من الالغام وتحدثت
يعني الامن الروسي الفيدرالي تحدث عن قيام
فرق مختصه بازاله هذه الالغام والتعامل
معها بغض النظر عن ان فرقا اخرى قامت
بمطارده فلول الذين تسللوا من الاراضي
الاوكرانيه ودفعهم للحفاظ على المدنيين
حسب الروايه الرسميه صهيبه اعود اليك رائد
لاسالك كذلك مره اخرى لفتني في كلامك
عندما ذكرت انه الجيش الروسي هو يطوق
باخمه بينما ضاجنر هي التي دخلت الى داخل
مدينه باخموت وهذا يعيدنا الى تصريحات
جديده ليافقيني قائد فاجنر يبدو انه مره
اخرى
عاتب او لاما القاده العسكريين في الجيش
الروسي ماذا قال بيغوجن
بالفعل صهيب يعني برجوجن دائما ما يطلق
تصريحات غريبه يعني في اليومين الماضيين
او حتى صباح اليوم كان هناك تصريح لبوتين
وطلب من رئيس مجلس الدوما الروسي بعدم
القاء اللوم على المقاتلين الذين يضحون
بدمائهم ويموتون في ارض المعركه بالباخمت
بل يجب محاسبه القاده الذين يخطئون ويتحمل
غيرهم مسؤوليه اخطائهم كانت هذه رساله
مؤسس مجموعه فاغنر لرئيس مجلس الدومه كل
يوم يطلق زعيم مجموعه فاجنر تصريحات
مهاجمه للقاده العسكريين وهذا يجعل الازمه
بين الدفاع الروسيه وقائد مجموعه باجر
تطفو على السطح من عبد الجواد في موسكو
اعود اليك لاسالك كذلك في اليومين
الماضيين كان هناك اختراق للاجواء الروسيه
بالطائرات المسيره الاوكرانيه اليوم كان
هناك اقتحام او تسلل بري في برياسك هل
هناك خشيه او ما مدى الخشيه من انتقال
المعركه الى داخل الاراضي الروسيه عبد
الجواب
صحيح يعني قبل دقائق تحدثت عن ان ريابكا
في نائب وزير الخارجيه الروسي ذكر بان على
موسكو الاستعداد للسيناريو الاسبوع طبعا
هذه هي القراءه السياسيه والعسكريه في
البلاد بان هذه العمليه وهذا التسلل اليوم
لن يكون الاخير ليست هي المره الاولى التي
تتعرض المناطق والمدن الحدوديه لضربات
اوكرانيه لكن الفارق الوحيد اليوم بين
الضربات الصاروخيه والمدفعيه وضربات
الدرون هو التسلل الى العمق الروسي طبعا
لدى موسكو قلق لا يمكن اخفاءه حول هذا
الهجوم والجميع بانتظار اجتماع الرئيس
الروسي فلاديمير بوتين يوم الغد مع مجلس
الامن الروسي على ما يبدو ان ملف التسلل
الى بريانسك سيكون نقطه الحوار بين الجميع
لذلك طبعا الاستعداد للاسوء تتحدث عنه
موسكو رسميا كما نلاحظ وبدا العمل بشكل
كبير من التجديد على النقاط الامنيه على
كافه الخطا الحدودي حتى ان طبعا
فارونج وهي المدينه التي تبعد عن العاصمه
الروسيه قرابه 400 كيلو متر نحو الغرب
باتجاه الحدود الاوكرانيه منع الطيران
كافه انواع المسيرات والرونات وحتى
للتصوير خلال يعني وفي سماء المقاطعه وفي
سماء المدينه
مراسله العربيه عبد الجواد الرشد ورائد
الاغبر كنتما معنا من موسكو دونيسك
بعد معركه ثلاثه اسابيع هزيمه الروسيه في
معركه ملحميه بين الدبابات منذ بدايه
الحرب في بلده
ظهر الاوكرانيه حسب وصف نيويورك تايمز
الامريكيه المعركه الكبرى حصلت في ظهر
جنوب اوكرانيا اسفرت عن انتكاسه كبيره
للقوات الروسيه
فقدت فيها روسيا ما لا يقل عن 130 دبابه
مما ادى الى فشل القوه الروسيه بالاستيلاء
على ظهر بعد ان ارتكبت نفس الخطا الذي كلف
موسكو مئات الدبابات في وقت سابق من هذه
الحرب حيث تقدم الدباباتها نحو الكمائن
بسبب نقص الخبره لدى القوات الروسيه
وتحديدا للمجندين الجدد الذين تركوا
العديد من وحداتهم النخبويه في حاله فوضى
[موسيقى]
الى الهند حيث انتهى اجتماع مجموعه
العشرين دون التوصل الى بيان ختمي مشترك
بخصوص الحرب في اوكرانيا في وقت ادانت
اغلب دول المجموعه فيما لم تتفق الصين
وروسيا وافاد وزير الخارجيه الهنديه التي
تتولى بلاده رئاسه قمه مجموعه العشرين ان
وزراء خارجيه التكتل توصلوا الى توافق
بشان العديد من القضايا بعد اجتماع
نيودلهي وركزوا على ما يوحدهم بعد ان
هيمنت الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه على
المناقشات
قال وزير الخارجيه الصينيه
خلال اجتماعي وزراء خارجيه مجموعه العشرين
في نيودلهي ان الصين ستحافظ على الاتصالات
والتنسيق مع روسيا على جميع المستويات
وحول الازمه الاوكرانيه ذكر بيان الخارجيه
الصينيه ان تشين ابلغ نظيره الروسي سر بان
الصين تدعم جميع الجهود المبذوله لدفع
المحادثات محادثات السلام ومستعده للاعب
دور بناء في هذا الصدد
وفيما يقرب العشر دقائق وبعيدا عن عدسات
التصوير تبادل راس الدبلوماسيه الامريكيه
والروسيه اطراف حديث غير رسمي على هامش
اجتماعي مجموعه العشرين في نيودلهي لاول
مره منذ عام اللقاء اذا بين انتوني بلينكن
ونظره كان قصيرا على وقع تدهور العلاقات
بين واشنطن وموسكو وتصاعد وتيره الحرب في
اوكرانيا بلينكين اراد خلال المحادثه
توضيح ثلاث نقاط وافقى ما كشفه مسؤولون
امريكي اولا التزام واشنطن بدعم اوكرانيا
وان على موسكو التراجع عن قرارها بتعليق
معاهده
وثالثا الافراج عن الجندي الامريكي بول
ويلا المحتجز في موسكو ومن خلال هذه
المحادثه القصيره مشاهدينا بين الرجلين
اكد المسؤول الامريكي انه كان واضحا انه
لن يكون هناك تغيير في في روسيا على المدى
القريب فيما يتعلق بالحرب في اوكرانيا
روسيا بدورها لم تعلق على فحوى الحديث لكن
المتحدث او المتحدثه باسم وزاره الخارجيه
الروسيه قالت ان بلينكن هو من طلب التحدث
الى لافروف واخر مره التقى فيها بلينكن
شخصيا كانت في جنيف في يناير 2022 عشيه
الحرب في اوكرانيا وحذر حينها بلنكن موسكو
من العواقب التي قد تواجهها في حال نفذت
عمليتها العسكريه المخطط لها
وجها لوجه على هامش محادثات مجموعه
العشرين
لقاء هو الاول منذ ازمه اوكرانيا على ارض
الهند محادثه على عجل لم تتجاوز 10 دقائق
اكد فيها بلينكن لنظيره الروسي ان واشنطن
ستواصل دعم اكياف عسكريا
وحظ فيها روسيا على الحوار لحل الصراع
والتراجع عن قرارها بتعليق معاهده نيو
ستارت للحد من الاسلحه النوويه قائلا انها
تصب في مصلحه البلدين والامن الدولي
كما استغل بلنكن الفتره الوجيزه ليطلب من
لابروف اطلاق سراح عنصر في البحريه
الامريكيه يدعى
وبحسب المسؤول فان بلينكن اراد نقله تلك
الرساله بعظمه لسانه الخارجيه الروسيه
بدورها اوضحت انهم مجرد تجاذب لاطراف
الحديث ولم تكن هناك مفاوضات والاجتماعات
رسميه
معنا عبر سكايت واشنطن بحث في مركز الدفاع
عن الديمقراطيات استاذ حسين اهلا بك معنا
في اخبار التاسعه صحيح الحديث كان جانبيا
ولعشر دقائق فقط بين بلانكن ولكن الى اي
حد هذا يكسر الجليد بين روسيا وامريكا
مساء الخير لا اعتقد انه هذا الحديث يغير
الكثير اعتقد انه كل من الرجلين خصوصا
الوزير الروسي استغل هذه الحادثه
لبعض يعني
الشعبيه في روسيا انه هو ارسل رساله انه
الامريكيين هم الذين طلبوا صحيح ان يلتقوا
بنا فهذه اعتقد ان هذه هذا هو الهدف
الروسي واعتقد انه بلنكن وقع في الفخ
وحاول بعد ذلك الاستدراك انه طلبته وطرحته
وهددته واقترحته لكن اعتقد انه هذه الجوله
فاز بها الوزير الروسي طيب ولكن حقيقه اذا
لم يكن الامر انه بالفعل انه طلب منه
انهاء هذه الحرب وما الى هنالك لماذا
برايك طلب بلانكن لماذا اراد بلنكا ان
يتحدث الى بعد هذه كل هذه القطيعه لاول
مره حقيقه لماذا اراد الحديث اليه
الحقيقه هي
فكره الدبلوماسيه لدى هذه الاداره
الامريكيه وهي فكره اثبتت فشلها في
اتفاقيه ايران النوويه الاولى واليوم في
الدبلوماسيه المتواصله مع ايران وتكرار
هذه الدبلوماسيه نفسها مع موسكو وهي
دبلوماسيه غريبه الاطوار غريبه النوع تقول
او يعني تنص على انه يمكن فصل العلاقه مع
اي دوله بين ما هو نووي وما هو غير نووي
هذا الامر لم يحدث مع ايران حاول اوباما
واليوم يحاول بايدن وهذا الامر لا يبدو
انه سيحدث مع موسكو هذه العواصم تقول
لواشنطن يعني نحن اصلا النووي اصلا الملف
النووي في ايدي هذه العواصم هو للافاده من
الملفات الاخرى
فهناك ايمان عجيب لدى بلينكن والفريق
الحالي بانه لديهم يعني سحر ما او
دبلوماسيه ما يمكن ان تفضي الا اتفاقيات
بالرغب عن الخلافه وهذا لم يحصل في السابق
ولا يبدو انه سيحصل الان
نعم طيب بالعوده الى اجتماع وزراء خارجيه
الدول مجموعه العشرين مره اخرى في هذا
الاجتماع يعني الاجتماع احبط الهند التي
استضافت هذا الاجتماع مره اخرى يكون هناك
اخفاق في الوصول الى
بيان ختامي مشترك قال لهذا الحد حجم الشرخ
كبير بسبب الحرب الاوكرانيه
اعتقد انه حجم الشرق حتى اكبر من ذلك يعني
من الغريب ان تتصور الكتله الغربيه انه
يمكن التوصل الى اي
اتفاق مشترك مع باقي الدول خصوصا روسيا
والصين يعني في وجود هذا الشرق طبعا روسيا
تحاول الافاده من كل منصه دوليه وهي نجحت
اليوم اولا في نفس البيان وثانيا في
التحايل على يعني غريب وضع الدبلوماسيه
الغربيه التي ترى انه يمكن للدبلوماسيه ان
تنجز ما لا تنجزه الامور الاخرى طيب من
خلال هذا الذي حدث في اجتماع العشرين في
نيودله استاذ حسين يعني هل تعتقد ان نهايه
هذه الحرب ما تزال بعيده على ما يبدو صحيح
اعتقد انها ما تزال بعيده جدا خصوصا انه
لدى روسيا اعتقاد انه يمكنها الفوز
والتغلب على الاوكران وطبعا الاوكرانيا
انهم بالدعم الغربي يمكنهم الدفاع ربما
التقدم باتجاه الحدود مع روسيا طالما
الوضع كهذا كذلك لا اعتقد ان الدبلوماسيه
في الوقت الحالي يعني هي الوقت المناسب
للدبلوماسيه بين الاثنين شكرا جزيلا لك
حسين عبد الحسين كنت معنا مباشره من
واشنطن عبر
التاسع مستمرا نتابع فيها بعد فاصل
من الجابون ايمانويل ماكرون يعلن انتهاء
عهد افريقيا الفرنسيه
[موسيقى]
مرحبا بكم من جديد في ايران يزداد الغموض
حول ظاهره تسمم مئات طالبات منذ اشهر ومعه
ارتفع منسوب الشكوك والاتهامات بعد ظهور
حالات جديده في 26 مدرسه في 6 مدن بينها
قم وطهران وبدات اصابع الاتهام تتجه الى
تبرط السلطات لاسيما بعد ان قمعت قوات
الامن عددا من اهالي التلميذات الذين
احتجوا على تلك الظاهره التي تهدد حياه
بناتهم وتزامنا مع الصمت الحكومي ارتفعت
الاصوات المطالبه بتوضيح موقف مرشد ايران
علي خامنئي
[موسيقى]
اذا المشاهدين روايتان حول سبب هذا
التصميم العمد لتلميذات المدارس في ايران
روايه الاولى هي لناشطينا ومحتاجين
ايرانيين ممن اعتبروا ان الغايه وراء هذه
الظاهره الغريبه والغاز المسمم شكل من
اشكال العقاب على العصيان المدني
والاحتجاجات التي اظهرت عبر الجامعات
والمدارس خلال التظاهرات الماضيه والتي
حملت شعار المراه حياه حريه عقب مقتل
الشابه ماسه اميني منتصف سبتمبر الماضي
اما الروايه الثانيه فهي وفقا لمسؤولين من
داخل النظام نفسه فهم يتهمون حركه معينه
تريد حظر تعليم الفتيات في البلاد على
غرار طالبان في افغانستان اما عن الطريقه
التي يتم بها نشر هذا السم فيقول نشطون
ايرانيون انها تتم عبر استخدام اشخاص
مجهولين للرذاذ او ادوات لرش هذا الغاز
السام الخفيف عبر تجنيد فتيات باستطاعتهم
الدخول
المدارس الفتيات او رش الغاز من خارج سياج
المدرسه نحو ساحه المدرسه وبالتالي تتعرض
الفتيات لاستنشاق الغاز وبالتالي الشعور
بالاعياء والغثيان طبعا هذا وفقا لروايات
ايرانيه اما عن النوع الغاز المستخدم في
عمليات التصميم هذه فوفقا لما اظهرت نتائج
فحوصات السموم التي توصلت اليها وزاره
الصحه ان الماده السامه المستخدمه في قم
تتكون بشكل خاص من غاز النيتروجين ان
اثنين المصنوع بشكل اساسي من النيتروجين
والمستخدم في الصناعه او كسماد زراعيه
[موسيقى]
وفي التعليق الغربي على قضيه التصميم
الفتيات في ايران اعربت المتحدثه باسم
مجلس الامن القومي الامريكي
خلقها من التقارير الوارده عن حالات تسمم
واسعه النطاق بين طالبات في مدارس ايران
واضافه واتسون ان حاله التسمم ربما تكون
مرتبطه بمشاركه الطالبات في الاحتجاجات
مطالبه بضروره المسائله واجراء تحقيق
مستقل ونزيح
اعلنت وزاره الخزانه الامريكيه فرض عقوبات
جديده على ايران وتستهدف هذه العقوبات
شركات وسفن شحن وبترو كيماويات بما في ذلك
عقوبات على 20 شركه شحن وتعد هذه العقوبات
اجراءا من الاداره الامريكيه بهدف محاوله
الحد من قدره الحكومه الايرانيه على جني
الاموال
المتحدثه باسم الحكومه البريطانيه في
الشرق الاوسط وشمال افريقيا روزي دياز ان
بلادها لم تسمح باستمرار طهران في
تصرفاتها المزعزعه للاستقرار في المنطقه
والعالم وذلك بعد الاعلان عن ضبط شحنه
اسلحه ايرانيه في خليج عمان في وقت سابق
دياز وعبر تغريده الله على تويتر اوضحت ان
ضبط البحريه البريطانيه لشحنه الاسلحه
الايرانيه المهربه يؤكد التزام بلادها
المتواصل بالتصدي للانشطه المهدده للسلام
والامن في المياه الاقليميه والامن البحري
الدولي بشكل عام
وفي ايران مره اخرى وفي وصف للوضع الراهن
للشارع هناك كتبت صحيفه الفرنسيه في تقرير
لها ان الوضع اشبه بالهدوء الذي يسبق
العاصفه الصحيفه عللت وصفها هذا بان الشعب
غاضب وقريبا ستستانف حركه الاحتجاج
وبانضمام اكبر الى صفوف المتظاهرين نتيجه
الوضع الاقتصادي المتردي في البلاد ونقلت
الصحيفه عن مصادر ايرانيه ان الاحتجاجات
الحاليه لم تفشل ولم تنتهي وان المتظاهرين
يعيدون بناء قواتهم ويراجعون تجربتهم
الاحتجاجيه لادراك اخطائهم من اجل اعاده
تنظيم انفسهم تدهور الوضع الاقتصادي
للايراني خلال الاسابيع الماضيه اصبح احد
العوامل العوامل الغضب الشعبي والقلق
المستمر بشان المستقبل بحسب شهادات تحدثت
معها الصحيفه الفرنسيه
[موسيقى]
خلال زيارته للغابون اكد الرئيس الفرنسي
ان عصر افريقيا التابعه لفرنسا انتهى ياتي
ذلك في اطار جوله افريقيه بداها ماكرون
بعد اعلان استراتيجيه فرنسيه جديده بشان
افريقيا
ندخل
تاريخنا المشترك هنا في الجابون دعونا لا
نخفي الامر هو ايضا تاريخ افريقيا التابعه
لفرنسا وعصر افريقيا الفرنسيه هذا انتهى
ولكن احيانا اشعر ان العقليات لا تتغير
بنفس السرعه حينما اقراوا اسمعوا اشاهد
الناس ينسبون الى فرنسا نوايا غير موجوده
وايضا متوقع الناس من فرنسا مواقف لا تريد
ان تتخذها وانا اتقبل ذلك تماما لهذا
السبب اريد ان اكون واضحا وصريحا في لقاء
اليوم في الغابون كما في اي مكان اخر
فرنسا هل يتحدث الجميع ويكون دوره عدم
التدخل في الشؤون السياسيه الداخليه
مراسل العربيه فادي الداهوك فادي اهلا بك
معنا ماذا يقصد الرئيس الفرنسي في تصريحه
هذا من الجابون بان مرحله فرنسا افريقيا
او عصر فرنسا افريقيا قد انتهى
اهلا صهيب البعض فهم من كلام الرئيس
الفرنسي انه يعلن انسحابا شاملا لفرنسا من
افريقيا لكن الرئيس الفرنسي وفي هذا
الخطاب الذي قاله قبل يومين من بدء جولته
في افريقيا انه لفرنسا ما يزال هناك مصالح
في افريقيا وهذه هي المره الاولى التي
يتحدث فيها بشكل مباشر عن مصالح فرنسيه في
افريقيا هو كان يقول انه سيعرض استراتيجيه
جديده هذه الاستراتيجيه لا تشكل باي حال
من الاحوال انسحابا فرنسيا وانما اعاده
تموضع للعلاقات بين فرنسا والدول
الافريقيه ولكن يسعى من خلال هذه
الاستراتيجيه عذرا للمقاطعه عن هذه
الاستراتيجيه الفرنسيه الجديده التي تفهم
على انها انسحاب حقيقه يعني انه فرنسا
يعني سحبت العديد من العسكريها من عديد
الدول الافريقيه في مقابل تواجد عوض هذا
الغياب الفرنسي والانسحاب الفرنسي وجود
روسي في بعض الدول الافريقيه ماذا نعرف عن
اعاده التموضع العسكري الفرنسي في القاره
السمراء
خلال الاشهر المقبله القليله المقبله
والكلام للرئيس الفرنسي سيتم خفض الوجود
العسكري الفرنسي
بالاصل وجود متواضع هذه المساله حتى الان
فرنسا تحتفظ بثلاثه الاف جندي متوزعين في
قاعدتين عسكريتين في النيجر وتشاهدها
القواعد العسكريه الفرنسيه كان الرئيس
الفرنسي تحدث انها ستتحول الى اكاديميات
وسيتم الاشراف عليها بشكل مشترك بين
القوات الفرنسيه ولكن ايضا من قبل القوات
المحليه لتلك الدول لان الدوري الفرنسي
كما نعلم تراجع بشكل كبير جدا وحلت قوه
امر واقع وخصوصا من قبل روسيا عبر
فاجنر وايضا الصين وتركيا اللتان تقومان
بتوقيع علاقات اقتصاديه وتجاريه مستمره مع
بلدان تلك المنطقه نعم ولكن يعني مساله او
هذا المصطلح مصطلح فرنسا افريقيا له وقع
سلبي عند الدول الافريقيه التي كانت
مستعمره من فرنسا ويعني بقاء النفوذ
الفرنسي على هذه الدول السؤال هنا هو ما
الذي يدفع فرنسا الان الى التخلي عن هذا
النفوذ في مستعمراتها السابقه في افريقيا
فادي
صحيح صهيب فرنسا كانت تفرض سياساتها
واجنداتها على تلك الدول من خلال مساعده
عدد كبير من قاده الدول في الوصول الى
السلطه لكن اليوم هذه المساله تغيرت اليوم
هناك راي عام شعبي جديد في تلك الدول هو
رافض للعقليه الفرنسيه التي ماتزال وفق
هذا الراي تتعامل مع دولهم منطق المستعمر
وايضا هم يرفضون
حكام دولهم الذين يعتبرون انهم مثيرين
للجدل وانهم ديكتاتوريين لذلك الوضع تغير
اليوم وايضا مشاعر العداء زادت بسبب وجود
القوات الروسيه وبسبب الدور التركي والدور
الصيني هذه المساله تحدث عنها الرئيس
الفرنسي بشكل واضح قال ان هناك ان هذه
القوه تقوم بدعايه ضد فرنسا في تلك الدول
وهذه الزياره او الجوله الافريقيه له سوف
تكون مواجهه هذه الدعايه ايضا
فادي الدهوك من باريس
[موسيقى]
اشار رئيس الحكومه الليبيه المكلف في من
مجلس النواب فتحي بشغه في مقابله خاصه مع
قناه العربيه ان حكومته اكتسبت شرعيتها من
مجلسين النواب والدوله والامم المتحده
اعترفت به كرئيس حكومه لكنها لم تعترف
بحكومته في المقابل قال ان حكومه الدبيبه
هي حكومه مؤقته ومحدده محدده المده بسنه
واحده وانتهت شرعيتها والبرلمان سحب الثقه
منها
حكومه تحصلت على منح الثقه من مجلس النواب
وايضا اناك رئيس وزراء وتبع هذا الاجراء
اجراء قبل يعني كان فيه اجراء من مجلس
الدوله
ان المجلس الدوله اذا كان ب 53 عضو وهو
كما ورد في الاتفاق السياسي الليبي اللي
تم توقيعه في سنه 2015 ربما يعتقد العديد
من الليبيين والغير الليبيين انه هو تم
منعي من الحكومه الولايه من المجموعات
المسلحه ولكن هذا غير صحيح
الامم المتحده لم تعترف بالخطوه لقام بها
مجلس الدوله
والبرلمان
واعترفت في البدايه كرئيس وزراء ولكنها لم
تعترف بالحكومه اوكت في مصداقيه التصويت
مع انه هو تم تسجيله بالكامل يعني بالصوت
والصوره دبيبه من ناحيه الشرعيه
لم يقويه لانه هو تم سحب اولا في الاتفاق
اللي تم في جنيف هي هذه الحكومه مدتها سنه
تقود ليبيا للانتخابات وتنتهي في شهر 12
واقصى مده لها كوعاء زمني بعد اجراء بعد
البدء وزراء الانتخابات هو شهر سته حتى
يتم تسليم والاستلام ما بين البرلمان
القديم والجديد وايضا
انتخاب الرئيس وانت الرئيس بانتخب رئيس
وزراء هذه كلها تحتاج الى حوالي اربعه الى
سته اشهر ولكن
ايضا انتهت شرعيته والبرلمان سحب منا
الثقه
مشاهدينا نذهب الان الى هونغ كونغو هذه هي
الصور الحيه من هناك حيث اشتعلت النيران
في موقع للبناء في منطقه للتسوق بالمدينه
واشتعلت النيران في طوابق متعدده من
المبنى وتطاير الحطام المحترق في الهواء
كما نتابع لم تشير التقارير حتى الان الى
وقوع ضحايا
وكذلك تمكنت عناصر الاطفاء على ما يبدو من
اخماد هذا الحريق بشكل كبير جدا يعني بقي
جزء قليل من هذا الحريق كما نشاهد في هذه
الصور الحريق اندلعها في موقع اسمه سيمشا
سوي في حوالي الساعه الحاديه عشره مساء
وهو مبنى مكون من طوابق متعدده في هذا
المبنى وهو محاط بمركز تسوق وبعض المباني
السكنيه والتجاريه مع عده فنادق في نفس
المنطقه اذا في هونغ كونغ نستمع قليلا
للصوت الطبيعي من الموقع
نعود بعد قليل في التاسعه ونتابع
في سلسله جولتها الحصريه شمال شرق سوريا
العربيه ترصد سلطويه نساء داعش وممارساتهن
القمعيه داخل مخيم روش
[موسيقى]
الن بكم من جديد في التاسعه حقبه قوانين
تنظيم داعش المتشدده وحكمه القائم على
الترهيب لم ينتهي بعد العربيه وضمن
تغطيتها الخاصه تمكنت من دخول مخيم روج
الذي تقيم فيه عوائل عناصر ومقاتلي داعش
الاوروبيين تهديده مبطنه وعلنيه قلبت
احوال المخيم الذي بدا بترويج صوره مختلفه
للداعشيات اللواتي خلعنا نقابهن لكن
الصوره تبدو اسوا واخطر في مخيم الهول
الذي تحول تقسمه منه لمراكز تعذيب وقتل
حيث شهد العام الماضي مقتل 36 شخصا على
ايدي خلايا التنظيم فيما يبرز دور اهم
للداعشيات في تنسيق العمليات الهجوميه
داخل المخيم وخارجه
[موسيقى]
نتفاوض معها للحديث بعد ان تملكها ارتياب
وتردد
قبل سنه فقط كانت كاساندار داعشيه
البلجيكيه وزوجه احد قاده التنظيم
المقتولين في الرقه تتحدث بثقه مع العربيه
عن قصتها كاول امراه تخلع النقاب في مخيم
روج
هيئتها تغيرت وقبضه خلايا التنظيم اشتدت
وان امتنعت عن تفسير تحولها هذا
محجبه غير منقبه بس يعني مختلف من بره بس
من جوا ما غير شي يعني
ماذا تقول ما
بدي نحكي من هذا
كانت رؤيه الكثيرات يتجولن دون غطاء راس
ممكنه هناك لكن اليوم 30 فقط بقينا دون
حجاب او نقاب ريان واحده منهن تقول انها
تعرضت للتهديد وعرضوا عليها اموالا
[موسيقى]
من مخيم روج انتقل الى الهول الاخطر على
الاطلاق
المواجهه الامنيه مع تنظيم داعش كانت اكثر
حصما ووضوحا لكن مواجهه فكره وارثه معركه
اخرى لم تحسم بعد هنا في مخيم الهول في
الحسكه نسخه متجدده عن تنظيم داعش اصغر
ولكنها ليست اقل تطرفا فلتنظيم هنا ممولون
خلايا التجنيد والتدريب كما له قوانينه
ومحاكم
الحسابات مختلفه هنا وكلها تخضع لقوانين
داعش ترهيب ما لا يلتزم بقوانين التنظيم
وحرق خيانهن او ايذاءهن جسديا هذه الصور
كافيه لشرح ما يحدث اربع نساء احتجزهن
التنظيم وقيدهن بالسلاسل في مركز تعذيب
اقيم سرا داخل مخيم الهول
[موسيقى]
لا تتوقفوا نساء داعش عند التعذيب العام
الماضي شهد المخيم مقتل 36 شخصا بينه
فتاتان مصريتان اكتشفت جثتهما في مجاري
الصرف الصحي حوادث كشفت عن دور المحوري
للنساء داخل خلايا التنظيم بينها تهريب
السلاح
لم يقتصر نشاط نساء داعش داخل حدود مخيم
الهول فالتحقيقات كشفت ايضا انهن حلقه وصل
رئيسيه لتنسيق هجمات التنظيم
في مخيم الهول قصه لا تنتهي هذا قسم
مستحدث يسمونه المنطقه الامنه ينقل اليه
من يثبت ان حياته في خطر بسبب تهديد خلايا
داعش
[موسيقى]
جنب مسجد
الثاني ولمن يضربوا حدا
الرصاص نسمع صوت رصاص يجيبوه مثلا
يشوف المكتوب الاحكام كانت تنفذ امام
المسجد
بعيد شويه يعني
الخطر يبقى قائما في مخيم تنشط فيه خلال
داعش وتسعى لكسر قيود الاحتجاز واعاده
تنظيم صفوفها ساره بنعيشوبا العربيه من
شمال شرق سوريا
وايضا في مقابله خاصه مع العربيه قالت
قائده عمليات الجزيره في قوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه دلبرين كوباني ان ثمانيه في
المئه من سكان مخيم الهول من زوجات وعناصر
داعش
هم زوجات واطفال عناصر داعش هناك اشخاص من
56 جنسيه مختلفه في مخيم الهول قتل
ازواجهن وابائهم في القتال او انهم
موجودون حاليا في سجون في شمال وشرق سوريا
[موسيقى]
توقع محللون في شبكه سي ان بي سي
الامريكيه ان تستفيد شركات عده من حظر
التيك توك من بينها
خاصه وان تعطيله ذات فرصه انتعاش بعد عام
2022 المطرب
مصائب تيك توك عند ميتا وسناب شات فوائده
فالتطبيق الصيني التابع لشركه باي دانس
حسم امر حظره في امريكا وكذلك كندا
وبدا من العشرين من مارس لتيك توك في
اجهزه ثمانيه الاف موظف في الاتحاد
الاوروبي ومن هنا شب نزاع اخر في الفضاء
الالكتروني بين اكبر اقتصادين في العالم
اشارت الى ان هذا الحظر قد يسمح لشركتين
ميتا وسناب شات ان تسحب بيسطى سوق
الاعلانات من تيك توك لتنتعش بعد عام
مضطرب اي انه نعمه لهما مقاطع فيروسيه
هكذا تصفها واشنطن خاصه انها تفشت بين
مليار مستخدما وفق بيانات مركز بيول
للابحاث سبعه وستون في المئه من
المستخدمين هم من مراهقين الولايات
المتحده
و16% من اليافعين يدمنون على استخدام
التيك توك
ومع قرار تعطيله سيتجه تدفق استخدام
الشباب الى المنصات الاخرى لتشغيل
فيديوهات فيسبوك وسناب شات سبوت لايت
وانستجرام
فبعد ان سجل التيك توك تحكما في اثنين
وثلاثه اعشار في المئه من الاعلانات
الرقميه في جميع انحاء العالم سيفسح
المجال بحظره لتفوق شركات اخرى
تعددت اسباب واشنطن في وقف استخدامه يقود
الامن القومي ويسرق البيانات الحساسه
ويؤثر على النمو العاطفي للاطفال
معترفه ولو ضمنيا بان ساحه الصراع باتت
رقميه اذ اسمت مشروع القانون ردع الخصوم
التكنولوجيين لامريكا
معنى من عمان رائد سموره الخبير في امن
المعلومات والناشر في موقع رابيوس التقنيه
مرحبا بك معنا رائد بدايه هل حقا تيك توك
خطر على الامن القومي ويخترق الخصوصيه
ويشكل تهديدا كما يقول الامريكيون
والاربيون ولهذا هم يستعدون لحظره
مساء الخير حتى نكون منصفين يا سيدي يجب
ان نتحدث عن كل منصات التواصل الاجتماعي
على انها تشكل تهديد للامن القومي لاي بلد
فعمليا استغلال منصات التواصل الاجتماعي
بالابعاد الامنيه بالابعاد الامنيه الخاصه
يعني بمعنى ابعاد تجسس ابعاد جمع معلومات
فهذا هذا المساله انا اعتقد انه كل منصات
التواصل الاجتماعي
تقوم بنفس امريكيه والصينيه تقوم تقوم
بنفس الشيء وبالتالي هم هم خوف الولايات
المتحده وكندا واوروبا من تطبيق تيك توك
لانهم لان تيك توك يقوم على ما تقوم عليه
التقنيات الغربيه اللي موجوده داخل
الولايات المتحده نعم نعم طيب هل تعتقد ان
هذا الحظر ستستفيد منه الشركات التواصل
الاجتماعي الامريكيه خاصه يعني فيسبوك وان
يعني ما هو حسب طبيعه الحظر استاذ اذا اذا
الحظر فقط في الدوائر الحكوميه العدد
محدود جدا في الدوائر الحكوميه ان كان
داخل الولايات المتحده وان كان داخل كندا
واوروبا فعمليا اما اذا كان في هناك حظر
ازاله التطبيق من الستورز هذه لها قصه
اخرى مختلفه تماما قد اكون قد اتفق معك
بما جاء بالتقرير واقول نعم من الممكن ان
يؤثر لكن
كلياتنا بنعرف انه عمليه المنع او الحجب
المؤقته
التقنيه فقط
يبدو ان الامريكيين يتجهون الى حظر عام
تيك توك في الاراضي الامريكيه بعد تفويض
من الكونجرس للرئيس بايدن بامكانيه القيام
بذلك ولكن دعني اسالك شيء اخر يعني مثلا
خدمه الريلز مثلا في انستغرام تشبه ما
يقدمه تيك توك من محتوى الفيديوهات
القصيره
على نفس المنصه على منصه تيك توك لكن
لماذا التيك توك انتشر اكثر من من
انستجرام في هذه المساله في مساله الريلز
خوارزميات انتشار
المحتوى في تيك توك تختلف تماما عن اي
منصه اخرى بالتالي هو حاز على نسبه كبيره
من الاعلان نعم الوصول
والفائده من الاعلان كانت على تيك توك
كانت متميزه بشكل كبير جدا بالتالي المعلن
هجر تويتر وهجر فيسبوك وهجر كل المنصات
وذهب الى تيك توك عمليا انا اعتقد حتى وان
وان تم حجب تيك توك انا لا اعتقد ان هذه
التطبيقات اللي موجوده الان سوف تستفيد
مصائب قوم عند قوم فوائده لا انا لا اعتقد
ذلك وانا انما اعتقد اذا تم ايجاد تطبيق
جديد منافس لتيك توك بذات الخوارزميات
لانتشار المحتوى انا اعتقد نعم سوف يعني
انت تعتقد ان الحظر ان الحظر لن يضر تيك
توك
ابدا نعم
شكرا جزيلا لك رائد سمور الخبير في امن
المعلومات وناشر موقع ارابيوس التقني
[موسيقى]
قلت المتحدثه باسم وزاره الخارجيه هي
الصينيه ماونينج ان على الولايات المتحده
وقفه مبيعات الاسلحه لتايوان وخلق عوامل
التوتر في المنطقه وذلك على خلفيه موافقه
واشنطن لتزويد الجزيره التايوانيه بصفقه
جديده من الاسلحه
تحوط الصين الجانب الامريكي على الالتزام
بمبدا صين واحده وبنود البيانات المشتركه
الصينيه الامريكيه الثلاثه ووقفي مبيعات
الاسلحه لتايوان اضافه لوقف العلاقات
العسكريه بين الولايات المتحده وتايوان
ووقف خلق عوامل التوتر في مضيق تايوان
ستواصل الصين اتخاذ اجراءات حازمه وقويه
للدفاع بحزم عن سيادتها ومصالحها الامنيه
واود ان اؤكد ان تايوان جزء لا يتجزا من
اراضي الصين فالسبب الجذري للتوتر في
تايوان وهو سعي سلطات الحزب الديمقراطي
التقدمي للاستقلال والانفصال وكذلك محاوله
بعض الدول استخدام تايوان للسيطره على
الصين
تزامنا مع حصولها على مزيد من الاسلحه
الامريكيه في صفقه جديده اعلنت القوات
المسلحه التايوانيه انها
اجرت مجموعه من التدريبات في شهرين مارس
وابريل على صدى الانزال البرمائي على ساحل
الجزيره بدورها اعلنت الصين انها ستتخذ
اجراءات حازمه وقويه للدفاع عن سيادتها
ومصالحها الامنيه وذلك في تصعيد جديد
للتوتر في بحر الصين الجنوبيه عقب
الاعلاني عن صفقه اسلحه امريكيه جديده
لتايوان والتي تعتبرها بيكين جزءا من
اراضيها وتطالب بضمها
تبدو هذه الاجواء هادئه نظريا لكنها
مشحونه بالتوتر مع كل حركه على الجانب
الاخر توتر قد ينفجر بمواجهه تعكر هدوء
المحيط الهادئ باكمله
وفي اخر توجهاتها السياسيه بشان الجزيره
التايوانيه وافقت على تزويد الاخيره بصفقه
اسلحه نوعيه امر اغضب بيكين واعتبرته
انتهاكا للالتزامات السياسيه بين الجانبين
الجديده بقيمه 619 مليون دولار تضمنت
صواريخ لمقاتلات اف 16 و200 صاروخ جو جو
متوسط المدى مضاد للطائرات اضافه لمئه
صاروخ من طراز بيهارم 88
وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه قالت ان الصفقه
الجديده ستساهم في قدره تايوان على الدفاع
عن مجالها الجوي والامن الاقليمي لترد
الصين بانها ستتعامل مع الامر بقوه وحزم
ستواصل الصين اتخاذ اجراءات حازمه وقويه
للدفاع بحزم عن سيادتها ومصالحها الامنيه
واود ان اؤكد ان تايوان جزء لا يتجزا من
اراضي الصين
الدفاع التايوانيه قالت ان الصواريخ
ستساعد في الدفاع الفعال عن مجالها الجوي
والتعامل مع ما وصفته بتهديدات واستفزازات
الجيش الصيني وذلك عقب توغل واسع النطاق
للقوات الجويه الصينيه في اجواء تايوان
باحدى وعشرين طائره خلال الاربع والعشرين
ساعه الماضيه فقط
وبين اصرار واشنطن على دعم الجزيره
التايوانيه واسرار بكين على ضمها يبقى
التوتر سيد الموقف ومخاوف من مواجهه قد
تقلب اجواء الهادئ والعلم الذي لم يتعاف
بعد من اثار حرب اوكرانيا
[موسيقى]
الولايات المتحده يبدو انها تخسر معركه
التكنولوجيا مع الصين وبالتالي ستخسر
واشنطن والدول الغربيه عموما التنافس
العالمي في المجال البحثي وفق تقرير معهد
السياسه الاستراتيجيه الاستراليه الارقام
مشاهدينا كشفت ان الصين ستقود مستقبل
الابحاث التكنولوجيه المهمه في العالم بعد
ان قادت سبعه وثلاثين من اصل اربعه
واربعين بحثا في قطاعات الدفاع والفضاء
والروبوتات والطاقه والبيئه والذكاء
الاصطناعي وغيرها من العلوم المهمه افضل
عشره معاهد بحثيه في العالم موجوده في
الصين ويقودها باحثون الصينيون مما يعني
انه على المدى الطويل ستصبح الصين المحرك
الاول للتكنولوجيا في العالم وحتى في
التقنيات المستقبليه التي لم توجد بعد
اكثر من ذلك فنحو ثمانيه واربعين في المئه
من الاوراق البحثيه عاليه التاثير بشان
محركات الطائرات المتطوره تقودها الصين
ايضا حسب التقرير والانجاز المدهش لها كان
في مجال الصواريخ فرض صوتيه في عام 2021
الامر الذي فاجا المجتمع الامريكي والغربي
لا توجد دوله مشاهدين اخرى قريبه من الصين
والولايات المتحده في السباق البحثي لكن
الهند والمملكه المتحده
تتصدرنا تتصدران المشهد اذا عن بعد
[موسيقى]
نشرت وكاله الفضائل الامريكيه ناسا مقطع
فيديو مصور من تلسكوب تفكك كويكب بعد ضربه
بالمركبه الفضائيه دارت تبع لوكاله الفضاء
في سبتمبر الماضي وسجل الفيلم بتقنيه
[موسيقى]
في تغطيه خاصه تبدا من العاشره صباحا
بتوقيت السعوديه السابعه بتوقيت تحت في
العربيه بالذكرى العشرين
لانطلاقتها في الثالث من مارس العام
2003 الدقه المتنوعه مشاهدينا من النشرات
ستتابعونها معنا غدا مشاهدينا في هذا
اليوم يوم العربيه في ترقيتها لذكرى
انطلاقها العشرين كل عام والعربيه
ومشاهديه بالف خير
اذا نهايه اخبار التاسعه هذا المساء اذا
تذكره بابرز العلوي
ات الفيديو
قتلان في تسلل بريانسك موسكو تعلن طردا
المنفذين خارج الحدود وكيف تصفها بفبركه
الروسيه
على اهم شيء اجتماعات العشرين في الهند
لقاء عابر بين بلينكن ولا بروبي ينتهي
بتبادل الاتهامات حول زعزعه الاستقرار
في ايران تصميم بالمدارس واعدادات في
السجون العفو الدوليه تكشف شنقه 94 شخصا
منذ بدايه العام الجاري
[موسيقى]
تزامنا مع حصولها على اسلحه امريكيه جديده
تايوان تجري مناورات تحاكم مواجهه انزال
بحري على الجزيره
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا اخبار التاسعه هذا المساء انتهت
شكرا لكم على كرم
المشاهده اذا بعد قليل الان مع زميله
ميسون وهضفي العربيه
360 نستكمل معك الفتره المسائيه هذا
المساء ميسون ماذا لديك في 360
حصلت في اجتماع مجموعه العشرين وايضا
الانقسامات في اوروبا تجاه الحرب
الاوكرانيه اما الملف الثاني الضغط الذي
تحاول ان تقوم به ايران لتحصل على اموالها
من العراق بينما العراق هو ملتزم بضوابط
الولايات المتحده طبعا هناك ملفات واخبار
اخرى اتمنى ان تتابعنا سنكون في المتابعه